- So we're going to talk
about your movie in a minute.
I swear cause that was really good.
Obviously, I messed up my intro,
but while we're on the
subject of your home life,
is it true that you have like
a dozen animals like horses or
you have like a lot of animals, right?
- I have a lot of animals, yeah.
- [Kelly] I love animals.
- Yeah, well come over anytime.
I have nine horses, five
dogs, eight chickens,
two bunnies and lots of wildlife.
Yeah. There's Bella with a horsey.
- [Kelly] Oh my Gosh.
- [Alyssa] And also my brother
just called me yesterday
and asked if I would take a mini horse,
which I haven't talked
to my husband about yet.
So I'm going to just take this
opportunity to let him know.
(laughter)
Wait where is the camera?
Which camera, which camera?
- Is he not into all the animals as you?
- He's not so into the animals.
- Okay. Go. It's right there. Go for it.
- Hi Dave.
We're adopting a mini horse.
So you know, it comes tomorrow.
- And Dave,
if you don't like the horse
we're going to know if the horse
doesn't make it at your
house, it was you all along.
That didn't want the horse.
So now you have it, the pressure's on.
I love that though, because
I love animals so much.
I think it's so good around kids too.
Just like the respect that
comes with it and taking
care of them and like
selflessness. It's so important,
but I have rabbits too.
And during Christmas it rained
so hard here that they dug
tunnels to each other.
And now, Alyssa...
- [Alyssa] There's lots of rabbits.
- They're about to be
born and I'm terrified.
So if anybody wants a Holland Lop...
- Dave, Dave. We're taking some rabbits.
(laughter)
- Dave, do you want a very
cute Holland Lop baby rabbit?
I was like, I didn't get them
fixed cause usually I do.
I listen to, you know, Bob and I was
get all your pets spayed and neutered,
but they weren't together
so I didn't do it.
And because I was like, I
don't want to make them go
into surgery if they
don't have to... they dug.
And I was like, you know
what? You earned it.
- Wow. Yeah.
- You dug, you earned
it, earned that moment.
Dug to each other twice!
Anyway a lot of bunnies.